[Music]
what's up everybody what's going on Lord
sovereign here for the iron Lords
podcast and Lords of gaming dotnet
coming to you live from the beautiful
IOP compound in West Hills California
today is the final day of III when
apparently the Lord's has saved the very
best for last
earlier this morning Lord Cognito had
the privilege of sitting in with CD
Projekt RED and their seminal RPG
cyberpunk 2077 he had a one hour demoing
of the game so just to give a little bit
of context of cyberpunk 2077 it's one of
the most anticipated games coming out
for any platform the next coming year is
coming out in March I believe it is
that's a mark ok so last year when the
game was originally announced and
showing a Microsoft stage everybody
thought it looked fantastic and
everything that we saw on screen was
basically in game engine and of course
last year press also had about a
one-hour demo that was not initially
released to the public that absolutely
blew everyone away in terms of the world
that they were showing in terms of the
depth they were showing it was
absolutely amazing so this year when
cyberpunk appeared on Microsoft stage
once again we got the the breathtaking
one Keanu Reeves coming out and showing
that the game looked even better than it
did last year and once again this year
the press was privy to about a one-hour
demo that showcased all the changes that
the game has gone through in the past
year so quickly I know this an initial
impression from kognito was blown away
amazing so I'll just give it to you
what were your impressions what did you
think just tell me everything yeah me
you listened CD Projekt RED man they've
definitely shown a lot of
care to this game obviously it's been
closed doors mostly every showing and
each time you know it gets more
phenomenal that you know next time next
iteration you see it the thing about it
off top is that the amount of detail and
scope in the [ __ ] the sheer scope of the
game is immense what they are trying to
do is very ambitious and the thing that
struck me off top is right off the back
of like you're in a custom creator so
they letting you touch the character
they letting you customize doing your
skinny doing your your clothing you're
doing your facial stuff very Mass Effect
style Skyrim style and on right off the
top Keanu Reeves there yeah so Keanu is
kind of like almost like a mentor
character he's not just like an
additional NPC he's a central character
to the game so he's talking to you and
it like literally when the character
creator finishes it's like oh no one
cares how you look just come on let's
hurry up let's go you know that kind of
situation so right off the top there and
then two things I notice off top was
there was some options as far as
personality traits so you had like um
Street Street punk or something like
that like Street wise and then you had
like corporate and then you had no man
and based on from my understanding based
on those choices it affects your
dialogue path in the game and how you
interact with other so if you're a
street punk do like if you go on through
messing with the ghouls you can see
through the BS quicker you know I'm
saying you'll be able to decipher you'll
get options that the other classes don't
even get same thing with um corporate
and so on and so forth so it's different
ways the few situations and also based
on your character besides those dialogue
options and is there anything else in
terms of all like in terms of stats that
is affected by those pre-canned sort of
a character option definitely see skill
tree um two things I've seen on top
there was a class called net runner and
he seemed very watchdogs he liked pretty
much anything he looked at he can
interact you can make you know the grill
go up you can make whatever a person is
next to interact with and do that kind
of stuff then I saw another class that
was calling like strong solo so he was
like picture Colossus from x-men right
so he had like the strong you know the
cybernetic arms
he's like busting through doors and he
is like more brute strength kind of a
thing but on definitely skill skill tree
and then also they had on almost Skyrim
like based on every little action you do
there's on you know okay you went +10 on
aggression
you went +10 on street-smarts your
personality goes up by doing it so every
little nuance interaction you're getting
some type of experience in the game and
stuff like that did you notice if those
small little nuances and changes
affected dialog choices as well
or was it so the smallest little change
was like I first saw out the top they
got charlie like iMac or like the street
version of akanda back as a man of color
I gotta be honest like prior to this
demo they had the one dude the brother
with the dreads and he was rocking out
and it looked good the most amazing
scene no doubt but this joint we was in
downtown Wakanda and you got to meet the
connect and the connect is like he's
like yo I want you to do a job you go
there he's not trustworthy sounded he
straight up sound like the child you
know there and did you going down there
and then like you meeting his people and
the cool thing was like you got to meet
him actor like like a little rendezvous
Church type situation with his peoples
is that and you go through the crowd
there's a whole ton of NPCs you're
interacting and then you get into the
middle and then the Kinect is dead with
the hoodie like and you say the little
password or whatever whatever and then
again first of all time I forgot one big
thing no loading on an outdoor
environment no loading whatsoever
seamless no loading indoor/outdoor no
loading with vehicles no load like you
going in and out seems then you can
change the perspective of the vehicle
Gant Grand Theft Auto style when you get
on a motorcycle third-person view or
up-close view then the literally CD
Projekt RED was saying when you're
seeing us pause we're just speeding you
further in the game because there's
really no loading here that part was
crazy so besides that you talked about
the aesthetics in downtown Wakanda what
did you feel like did you feel it felt
like a world that was lived in did you
feel like the NPCs that were walking
around were
doing their own thing not necessarily on
a routine you felt that they were alive
in this world
because I think we're even with Witcher
3 when you start doing your side
question whatever you feel like these
people really inhabit this world yeah
definitely I definitely felt like the
characters had different paths they were
going there was also the person who was
presenting said one part of town that we
were like don't stay around that part of
that hood too long because dudes would
pop off like so
everybody has specific they had specific
on paths and NPC things that they do
throughout their normal day did you
notice a real day/night cycle didn't see
it off top so I'm not gonna say it
doesn't exist I don't want to say you
know but at the end I mean where I saw
it kind of started off day you met with
the connect you met with their own I
think name was plac'd or whatever and he
was the efficient person that wants you
to do this job to infiltrate something
that they don't want to do
you're not saying and then that's when
the story takes off from that point okay
so one thing that I found interesting
about the first time that I got to see
cyberpunk was the idea of hacking and
how that is integral to the entire world
and how you interact with the world and
how you're able to manipulate things
kind of in a way that I like I recall
Deus Ex like things we can do like that
did they show more of that was that more
expansive than the last time always
crazy because like all right there's
this group of goons that you gotta
infiltrate right they caught the animals
right throws the buff goos they didn't
be juicing out right don't do this right
they hide out it's like a gym okay right
so there's one point where here they're
showing you they said you couldn't
attack this whole situation stealth wise
so they start off the demo that way
you're hiding behind there's dudes in
there about the hitting rack and all
that and then literally as you look at
your with your cybernetic hack thing you
can bring the weights down on him and
kill him on a sec you could do all type
of things to everything and if I saw
again that part was very watchdogs you
don't say and I loved that part then the
same scenario again that was a class I
believe was called the net runner right
he's the one that's very hacked base but
on that specific mission the way they
were telling us there was another rogue
netrunner watching us so if you hacked
in he knew you was dead so if you did
that it was gonna alert that person if
you ran
class they did the same scenario run it
back and this time it was like that
strong solo class he didn't do any of
that right
you don't hack you brute forced away
found another path right and then you
can mix it up or I'm gonna tell you what
was crazy good there's one point where
you do go guns blazing how how many
different ways can you approach every
scenario you can actually you know
hacking obviously combat obviously are
they're just dialogue options that let
you to smooth your way that something
yes yes you got that so I saw the
dialogue joint again I think one was the
street punk one to do was trying to
finesse you cuz it's a part where all
right in order to do the job he's got a
hack into you and apparently it's hard
part that's not what you let that's not
what you do you don't let nobody get
control of your vital sense to him and
then cuz basically he wanna see through
your eyes when you go go infiltrate so
did they say if that's some sort of
failed state if you allow that to happen
or how do they even show you what
happens if that happens they show they
show the scenario that okay you do grab
my hand and say yo all right you ready
you could pull your hand back like fan
what you're doing like we don't do this
here that's not that's not what happens
so he's like look you know you and this
is the details of the arrangement it was
not going down now they didn't show us
the option if you continually
continually refused what what happened
then
but they just gave the option okay you
know what go back in or hey street smart
you know I'm saying I'm not stupid
you know that kind of a deal so they
give you three paths and they're very
they're very different very pad that
goes on different branching paths ok so
then going into a little more detail on
the actual combat how did you find
gunplay to be how do you find the guns
to feel did they sound like like they
were powerful I tell me a little bit
about a combat scenario alright not
wholly negative I gotta say is not that
the combat was whacked like when he was
getting busy with the shooting it was
good he was shooting everybody
um they the enemies had um like level
numbers on them so like level 33
whatever whatever and then on like even
the main connector would talk to he was
like very high levels obviously I'm
assuming you could just bust off if you
don't want to do the job or whatever
that's fine but the thing what I noticed
is when you're shooting I didn't feel
like that
you know that ragdoll kind of thing okay
I could I felt could have been a little
bit more visceral and actually during
the demo they asked you that you
actually if you have any negatives any
things you want them in approval
I said little that's the only thing I
felt if I had to nitpick I feel it could
have been the guns don't pop enough for
me for me I can for some people they're
gonna be fine for me is it that's to be
god I got the best gun playing you don't
say I like to hear you don't same kind
of thing so when you talk about the like
the how the guns pop but how about how
damage is taken so you mentioned no
ragdoll or whatnot did you feel like
could you shoot specific limbs did they
react to this shoot getting shot in a
specific area because I could have swore
maybe I'm wrong about this but I could
have sworn the older demo had something
like that where it seemed like it like
the combat could be really gruesome
right the old demo did a better job of
that now again it could be because of
the enemy NPCs refined these guys called
the animals big brolic duel you know
saying maybe that's just hot a react so
when they get shot this one part where
you do kind of fight like a like a sub
boss kind of character and he had like
this thing on the back that was giving
him implants and making his strength
keep rising during the entire battle
right and if you don't hit that spot the
fight gets longer and longer and
remember I told you if you ran as a net
runner and you hacked it got all the way
to that point the net runner is now
assisting that guy and hacking your
system making your screen go blurry and
there's like a timer so on the fly
you're trying to combat the net runner
and physically combat this guy it's
crazy bro it's crazy Wow okay so we've
talked about the main aspects of the
game in generally it go through exactly
what the demo showed you that what was
the scenario and then what was the end
game of the scenario basically what it
seemed like
is the the Cadi NPC that you were
meeting up right I'll call him know what
kind of goons like basically what he
wanted you to infiltrate they had it
they had a van that they were monitoring
and they noticed that it was in this
other industrial area and they felt like
this government agency has a play and
apparently I forgot the name of a maybe
like a net watch or something like that
but they're a very integral character to
the game right so you're basically doing
this job there's guys hacking into you
so that'd make sure that you ensure the
job is done and then he's actually
you talking play-by-play while you're
going through you get to like a boss
area you beat the boss whatever and then
again based on if you pick not run or a
strong solo you eventually gonna meet
that actual agent that government agency
thing then the game comes down to a very
serious dialogue choices because you
roll up on them you can eat at that
point that guy's totally look I know the
Makana dude said you know I'm saying
pacifica die he said look they gonna
kill you as soon as you do this job it's
over they're gonna trust that's what
they do
he said you're an outsider that
community work with me and he's making a
convincing argument right so you got the
option to complete the job lace amount
tack him into you know to the arm double
kind of dues and then that's got to be
your mission so I believe at that point
the demo person agreed to give over the
information so we you know he dropped
her on the government agent hacked into
him at that point then you wake up cuz
they did do you dirty do you dirty and
then the Keanu Reeves character who was
kind of like your mentor because again
the vibe the story seems very mysterious
but the vibe I'm getting is what makes
your character special is there's some
implant chip in your brain it's almost
like an anomaly and that Keanu Reeves
character is like a ghost guy that talks
to you that's like your mentor
use your Cortana is your cut Ronny
exactly you know I'm saying so that
that's pretty much what that was so that
kind of saves you and then when you get
out of the situation you know most
people like most cybers don't survive
something like that so they give you the
option like yo you want to pull up on
them do they that that double
double-cross you yeah so that that was
the situation I played out Wow okay so
now that you've seen this let's talk
over
let's talk tech specs what was it
running on PC definitely running on
peace because there was some talk there
was some talk that was running on ps4
pro at one point so maybe that changed
or maybe they had different demo
stations so this was running on PC what
did you see in terms of in terms of tech
stuff what we did was it running at 60
resolution I would say it's definitely
30 it's not it's nothing again this mean
they're picking but I was yeah it's
an open-world game no loading you know
again PC rig but it's definitely 30 was
not 60 I will want out he's coming I
want to make about during the fights
though I know I'm giving the game a
little you know nitpick with visceral
body shots and I forgot to give it up to
the AI though because they again that
group the animals another part of the
little steroid cycle thing that they do
is that they got enhanced super speed
okay so there was one point when you
shooting and mixing it up and it dude is
like boom boom and runs down on you like
he's weaving to get to you and all those
effects look oh look beautiful because
it's like the flash like the election to
get up on you you know say and then oh
one critical part as a strong solo
character give you like the guns blazing
style there was a part where the net
runner prior during this during the
firefight hack the turret
use the turret to shoot you know the
enemy and stuff like that had to do by
like he had like a grenade in his pocket
almost watchdogs II blow up do all that
so you had that but then what was dumb
about the strong long character that
same turret when they replayed the
situation as did the other side will do
with the other class he grabbed the
turret yanked it off the joint like
Terminator 2 style and you had like was
really good
like it was crazy okay so in terms of
your character kid you spec yourself to
be even across the board if you wanted
to or do they want you to sort of lean
in one way or another okay
definitively say the vibe I got was that
it was very open flowing as far as your
said they basically showed a stat menu a
lot of stuff they did say menus still
work in progress for certain things
certain things are still not final so
the what I saw it looked the trees look
like you can spec evenly how you want
right but again in their defense they're
saying look not final still things that
to be determined that kind of thing so I
don't know if they've really dug deep
yet on how they want to go what orchids
but the vibe I got is there's definitely
archetypes based on the skills you play
they did confirm it yeah and it more
than like you get special bus if you go
with a certain artist
but you can sort of just make you can
make your get your guy from the ground
up the way you want okay again it's not
what I would expect that especially in a
world you know cyberpunk world the
hacking is such a big thing so one other
thing I wanted to ask in terms of like I
mentioned before the side quests right
beside question witcher 3 were amazing
because it felt like they were either
very interesting on their own or some
way shape or form doubled back on the
overarching story right did they do any
of that or they just showed you that
direct path sort of and and and how you
could differentiate the direct path that
they were showing you in this specific
demo or did they say hey talk to this
guy if you want and do something like
that it was along those lines the demo
they were keeping us on Rails right but
you can tell you can go off rails
because there were characters doing
their own thing with dialogue that you
know you can interact with and lead you
into a hold of a path there was one part
before our meeting up with the plac'd
character who's I believe is to connect
for the job
there was like a guy shooting up at the
government agency things that was
watching and it's like cool is if so
many NPCs and everyone doing their own
thing Shenmue style or whatever you want
to say that you it be game the game does
not hold you back on exploring you know
say it really wants you to it's just for
the sake of the demo they're telling hey
we're gonna go here we're gonna do this
for a second we're gonna go here we're
gonna do this but there's no guarantee
there's no doubt in my mind you can go
out all the way and explore those things
I got to tell you man like everything
you said so far it's rare that you have
a certain level of expectation for a
game and that it might exceed that meet
it is one thing right meet it is another
thing that sometimes that never happens
to exceed it is even is even more
amazing and it you know it's you want to
hear like when you listen to people
talking about the game you think it's
just hyperbole because everybody's like
oh my god oh my god oh my and again I
know you were excited for it but you
didn't really play The Witcher 3 too
much you haven't really experienced what
what a CD Projekt RED game is like right
so if you want to compare this to what's
out there now
and what's what we know is coming and
you know and but does I love you but we
got to talk about this start comparing
it to what you've played so far right as
a matter of fact I'm playing Kingdom
Come deliverance right now my PC and
that is a game that is it relishes in
the little things right and that's what
makes it interesting that it's the my
new details of what makes it great right
um I think it seems like this is even
taking it a step up so beyond Kingdom
Come any other things you should kind of
saw compare it to and say you know they
got to be on watch everybody will watch
I'm gonna tell you right now listen
listen I don't care what I am so glad I
saved this appointment for last I am so
glad because I would the ball is so here
with CD Projekt RED right now that it's
like looking at anything else no
disrespect to no other developer is just
like right now they are so in their bag
with it feels next-gen so the thing that
closes things I can say first of all if
you're a tech guy if you love things
like the matrix if you the whole
ambiance of this world is very
futuristic very tech that hits so many
personal notes for me the techie gig you
know saying that off rip there you dokie
on Owen who's now a central part now you
already get matrix vibes off rip so you
like okay you good now gameplay wise
this is for you Mass Effect fans that
love your dialogue choices that love
waited this every little nuances is
weighted it anything is different to
Mass Effect right Mass Effect obviously
it's an older game they did what they
could with those dialog branches but
like I said when you see The Witcher and
you see this little and Nakia storyline
that you think is nothing and somehow
doubles back yes the greater story
you're like how did they manage to weave
this and not mess everything up exactly
and that's the evolution of it right so
that's that dialogue system and again
what this is gonna be a game that you're
gonna play multiple times over because
you're gonna see what you can't do based
on what you don't have
trunk it's not like simple mass effect
weights two choices no sometimes five
right sometimes is - sometimes it's
three but this model and it'll be like
yo no man can say that street punk could
and it couldn't go home laughing that's
the thing because it's not it's not okay
three choices that expand into a weave
of maybe another two choices right it's
three choices that each one has an
extension that goes maybe three or four
different ways so this is the single
player selfish experience this is all
you and it's all me because I've again
no disrespect to the Witcher is just
that you know I love tech I love
futuristic stuff I love cybernetics all
the sci-fi if you're a sci-fi person is
it's on so again it's like yo this right
here is gonna hit a lot so again for me
right now it's like this it's like Mass
Effect Witcher watchdogs had a baby and
it's now some next-level overworld type
situation it's perfect and it's perfect
so so you're saying that that that yeah
I'll just grow six better step it up
everybody I don't know how they doing it
on this generation I'm almost tempted I
think I'm almost tempted to play it on
generation all wait to to November when
we get the new consoles and play it on
the new consoles because I know it's
gonna be a cross-gender game it's
definitely one of those games it's gonna
be crossed at I tell you right now man
just by you talking about it and again
not everybody got a chance to see this
I'm hoping at some point it makes his
way to the internet like the last one
did because they said the same thing is
like nobody's gonna see this except the
president months later it came out so I
hope people get to see this and people
that maybe are on the fence about it
whether it's because it's a sci-fi game
whether it's because it's an RPG that
not into RPGs I think what Witcher began
to do and what cyberpunk is continuing
to do is sort of melding the genres
where if you're somebody who likes
combat and like action you're gonna have
that game and you can work you can mold
the game to your play style and if
you're deep into true RPG mechanics it
still there because I think some
something that mass effect got a little
a little crap for alone is that they
simplified it too much and it took out
the RPG mechanics yes and I don't think
I think this is able to do both things
without sacrificing either
I'm richer and I think that's the
perfect marriage because it's like it's
still sometimes some games get a little
too overwhelming and I didn't feel that
with this I still I felt it's deep I
feel its depth there I just feel that
it's gonna it's gonna hit a lot of
nuances that people are gonna fall in
love it's a lot of tropes that people
are gonna fall in love with and I'm
excited to see what they way to go with
this I mean graphically there's a few
things that's touching it as far as like
the character models themselves the
faces the animations top-notch stuff and
like I said I mean just going like I
said he jumped on a bike to drive to a
certain location you know you're
switching their views and you're just
seeing this seamlessly non-stop no
transition everything it's truly
remarkable what they're doing CD Projekt
RED is got one minute okay so the
release date is less than a year away
based on what you saw you believe it
yeah I mean they look I mean listen you
know the games like this the scope is
pretty large you know so they give any
indication how percentage-wise it how
far along they are not any good
percentage but I just talked about
I guess the vibe I'm getting is they're
fine-tuning menus and different little
skill sets for balance and stuff like
that but it do it I'm not gonna it feels
like it's it's it's on its way
I mean who know I basically it's gonna
be determining based on how big the
scope of it and based on their track
record what you play didn't feel like a
vertical slice that was created for it's
no pick the part of the game they were
working on and showed it literally said
like we're in the middle like right here
like yeah this is no vertical slice no
no foolery no for ordering this was the
real deal in my opinion and I'm saying
again it was controlled in a sense yes
they had one person playing and I
letting us play it but they're showing
the joint you know saying yeah I'm
telling y'all right now man shout out
the CD Projekt RED man they show
tremendous love the Lords of gaming that
net honored to actually get a chance to
to witness it and um the tradition to
look out for this is the one to look out
for you guys anybody on the fence this
is the game and
a guy who may not be the biggest Witcher
guy you know I do understand the
evolution and why people love that
series and for my tech heads this is
y'all this is for you man it's crazy
because when you look at The Witcher 3
and what it evolved from right Witcher 1
is a very different game what you're -
as great as it is this is a very
different game - Witcher 3 to think that
maybe this is this is a franchise right
there's not just one game and to think
that 2077 is the ground floor and to
think about what maybe the third game in
that series like it's kind of nuts but
again like you said shout-out to CD
Projekt RED for a life for saying you
know what we see what's out there
we're gonna take it up a notch United
with a swag rep but now Real Talk salute
CD Projekt RED I cannot wait to see the
journey as you guys continue shout out
to the presenters see that believer name
was Kelly tremendous really immersed you
in the world got you in the sense of
every aspect of what was going on -
every scene every dialogue every way -
decision every option every counter
option you know it just she just showed
this that it's not scripted and and the
the amount of things you can do is vast
so solution II Projekt RED Lords the
game of that exclusive you already know
and we out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
v-mon and you made it you blown up all
over the news are you alone I just want
the money you got the chip all right
start it up back why don't you go to the
bathroom wash up we gonna be with you in
a minute
aha come on man your neck it's a mess
initiating combat mode destiny all right
in and out [ __ ] we're rich oh we are
going to the major leagues Jackie
oh okay
get to clinic now it's toilets condition
critical immediate launch hey hey
just think about all the good [ __ ] we're
gonna have huh oh sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
take the [ __ ] shift X every corporate
cop in this city is gonna be blasting
down these doors after what you and your
psycho friend here we didn't need all
this [ __ ] attention damn it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wake the [ __ ] up samurai we have a city
to burn